so just a quick review of what we were
doing in the last video we had this
oddly shaped pipe
and you know i had this the fluid coming
in had an input velocity v1 the pressure
on the the left-hand side pushing to the
right is p1 and its velocity i already
said the velocity and the area of this
hole is a1 and what we and and of
everything has you know the same
variables with the two on it is coming
out of the pipe
and what we just set up in that last
video is we said well by the law of
conservation and of energy the the
essentially the joules the joules the
energy
at this point in the system or that
we're putting into the system has to be
equal to the energy coming out of the
system
and so
we use that information to set up this
big equation but it's not too
complicated we figured out that the work
going into the system was the input
pressure times the mass of volume over
some period of time
divided by
divided by the density of whatever type
of liquid we we had the potential energy
this is just typically mgh where the
mass is the mass of this column of fluid
right we're kind of saying how much work
was done over some period of time t
essentially that that's the way i would
think about it how much energy was there
over some period of time t
and the kinetic energy over that period
of time would have been the mass of
this volume of of fluid times its
velocity squared divided by two that's
typical kinetic energy right and of
course that has to be equal to
essentially the output energy and so
this is the output work
the output work or essentially how much
work a column of water could do on the
output side
so and it's an equivalent volume of
water remember that so in some period of
time t whatever volume of water this was
in in some period of time to an
equivalent volume of water maybe it'll
be a longer cylinder now
because it's going to be going faster
so on the output side it's this longer
cylinder that we're talking about but
it's going to be the same volume and the
same mass so what we say is that the
output the work that this column can do
in that same amount of time
would be the output pressure times the
mass of this column divided by the
density of the column which is the same
because
the density of the liquid is the same
throughout
times
the mass of this column which is the
same as the mass of of this column
because uh the volume hasn't changed so
and the density hasn't changed so
they're the same mass
although now this column has more
potential energy right it's it's up at
h2 which i'm assuming is higher than h1
and then his kinetic energy is just the
mass of this of this cylinder of fluid
times its velocity squared which is the
output velocity divided by two so this
is
this is potential energy out
and this is
kinetic energy out
and these equal each other so we this
setup this is bernoulli's equation but
let's let's see if we can clean it up so
that we can get rid of variables that we
don't have to know about so one thing
that we see there's an m in every term
so let's get rid of them divide both
sides of this equation by m
dividing both sides of this equation by
m we get that
and let's uh i don't know i don't like
this density in the denominator here so
let's multiply both sides of this
equation by density and what we're left
with is let me write this in a vibrant
color
p
the input pressure
plus we're multiplying everything by
this row this you know this density so
we have input pressure plus rho
g
h1 the input height the initial height
plus
rho
v squared
over
two you're probably expecting me to say
row v wade but no this is rho i'm a bad
joke
this is rho v squared over two
and that equals we multiplied both sides
by rho so we get
the and this is the input velocity
the row the the so that equals the
pressure out
plus
the density
times gravity times the output height i
don't know we could well
let's make everything consistent i wrote
twos here so let's just let me say this
pressure two this is height two
plus
rho
times the velocity
squared
the output velocity squared this is
bernoulli's equation and it has all
sorts of
what i would say is is fairly neat
repercussions for example it tells us
that
let's assume that the height stays
constant so we can ignore these middle
terms if the height is constant if i
have a higher velocity
if i have a higher velocity
and this whole term is constant then my
pressure is going to be lower right
think about it if let's ignore if height
is constant this doesn't change
but if this increases if velocity
increases but this whole thing is
constant pressure has to decrease
similarly if pressure increases
then velocity is going to decrease that
might be a little unintuitive but the
other way it makes a lot of sense when
velocity increases this pressure is
going to decrease and that's actually
what makes planes fly and all sorts of
neat things happen but we'll get more
into that into a second but let's see if
we can if we can use bernoulli's
equation to do something useful and you
should memorize this and it shouldn't be
too hard to memorize you know it's
pressure and then you have this kind of
potential energy term but instead of
mass you have density and you have this
kind of kinetic energy term it's not
kinetic energy anymore because we
manipulated it some but instead of mass
you have
density
so with that said let's let's do a
problem i'll keep this down here since
you probably haven't memorized it as yet
let me erase everything else
that's not how i wanted to erase it
but let me see if i can
oh that's how i wanted to erase it i
wanted to erase it like that
without getting rid of anything useful
okay that's good enough
and then let me
clean up
clean up all this stuff
clean up this stuff so let's say that i
have a a cup
a cup
let me well i'll just draw a cup
easier to draw sometimes than to draw
straight lines and all of that that's
too dark do purple
and that i'm using the super wide tool i
have to switch the layer okay so that's
my cup it has some fluid actually let's
say it has a top to it
it has a top to it and i have some some
fluid in it
maybe it happens to be red we haven't
been dealing with red fluids as yet
so let me uh
oh i didn't want to do that
so let's just you know you know there's
a fluid there and let's say that there's
no air here so this is a vacuum
and let's say that
h
we don't know what units are but let's
say h meters below the surface of the
fluid so this is all fluid here right
i poke a hole i poke a hole right there
and and fluid starts spurting out
fluid starts burning out
and my question to you is
what is this output velocity
of of the fluid as a function of of this
height and let's say let me tell you
something else let's say this hole is so
small let's call it the area of that
hole a2
and let's say that the surface area of
the water is a1
and let's say that hole is so small that
the surface area of the water let's say
that a2
is equal to
1 1000
of a1 so this is a small hole relative
to the surface area of of this cup right
so with that said let's see what we can
do about figuring out the velocity
coming out well bernoulli's equation
tells us that the input pressure plus
the input potential energy plus the
input kinetic energy is equal to the
output et cetera et cetera et cetera so
what is
the
input
pressure well the input pressure
the pressure at this point there's no
air or no fluid above it so the pressure
at that point is zero input pressure is
zero
what is
the input height well let me let's just
assume that this is this that the hole
is done at height zero h equals zero
so the input height
h1 is just h right
if this is zero then this
height right here is h
and what is the input velocity
well we know from the continuity
equation or whatever that thing was
called we know that the input velocity
times the input area
is equal to the output velocity times
the output area
output area
and we also know that
we also know that the output area is
equal to one one thousandth of the input
area
right
so
this is area two
so we know that the input velocity times
area
one is equal to
the output velocity times one one
thousandth of area one so we could say
area one over a thousand
divide both sides by area one
so we know that the input velocity is
equal to
v2
over a thousand right
so that's good to know so these are the
three
input three inputs into the left-hand
side of bernoulli's equation
and what's on the right-hand side of
bernoulli's equation
well what's p2
what's p2
what's the pressure at this point
well oh i just ran out of time i'll
continue this into the next video